Professor John Rogers:
We ended the last lecture,
or actually I ended my last
lecture -- The last lecture was
Matt's -- I ended my last
lecture on Paradise Regained
with the brief consideration
of the riddle of the sphinx.
Satan was compared to the
sphinx who had thrown herself
off the "Ismenian steep" when
her riddle had been discovered.
The Son of God,
you'll remember,
was implicitly compared to
Oedipus, who had figured out the
riddle of his own identity by
means of his exchange with the
sphinx.I think it can be
said that Samson Agonistes
is more explicitly concerned
with riddles and with riddling
even than Paradise Regained
was.
One of the key moments --
although this isn't anything
that Milton does very much with
-- one of the key moments of the
story of Samson that we get from
the Book of Judges in the Bible
involves Samson's posing of this
big riddle: the riddle of the
honey and the lion.
It's Samson,
at least in the Judges version
of the story,
who can be seen as assuming the
role of the sphinx.
He poses the riddles,
and it's really his duty
throughout his life to know when
it is you should reveal the
answer to the riddle,
to the secret.
Samson Agonistes is,
I think, profoundly interested
in this problem and is
continually asking the question:
how do you know when it's
time--how do you know when it's
time to reveal your secrets?
Or -- to use the language that
Milton uses in the seventh
sonnet, "How soon hath time?"
-- how do you know when it is
that you have ripened?
That's a riddle that it's the
job of Samson in Samson
Agonistes to figure out the
answer to.Now,
it's one of the ironies of
literary history that this poem,
which is really all about
riddles and secrets,
surely poses the biggest riddle
for the scholarly,
the academic,
study of Milton.
It has proven nearly impossible
for scholars of Milton to
determine when it was that
Samson Agonistes --
to determine authoritatively
or definitively when it was that
this text was written.
In that respect,
it's utterly different from the
other works of Milton's that can
be dated much more
authoritatively.
We do know this.
It first appears in 1671;
it's published alongside
Paradise Regained.
So you have the title page
of that 1671 volume,
"Paradise Regained, a
poem in four books,"
and then in a little typeface,
"To which is added Samson
Agonistes."
Actually the Hughes
edition reproduces for
you just this title page -- it's
on page 470.
But there's no hard evidence
for the date of the composition
of the poem, and there are
conflicting accounts,
as of course you can imagine,
of the date of
composition.So I want to
spend a little bit of time here,
and I'll just do this briefly,
thinking about the various
scholarly accounts of when it
was that Milton wrote Samson
Agonistes,
because all of these
theories, I think,
concerning the placement of
Samson Agonistes in the
Miltonic canon assume in one way
or another that this poem is
autobiographical -- that there's
some kind of intimate,
autobiographical component to
this remarkable work.
The assumption is that on some
level Samson Agonistes
almost necessitates a type
of biographical reading.
So first, and this is the most
popular theory of the dating of
the poem and it's the one I
happen to,
and that most people,
subscribe to -- it's the theory
that places Samson Agonistes
as Milton's last poem,
which means that this is a poem
that's written well after the
middle of the 1660s.
Milton seems to have started
writing Paradise Regained
around 1665,
so it would have been after
that at some point,
well into the Stuart
restoration.This reading
really suggests, to the
extent that this is a thematic
reading of the poem,
that Samson is like
Milton, the great political hero
or the erstwhile great political
hero.
Samson had almost led the
Hebrews to freedom by destroying
so many of the Philistines with
his extraordinary,
divinely inspired violence,
but the Hebrew leaders failed
to join Samson in this mission.
They ruined their chance for
freedom from the Philistine
yoke.
In the 1650s and in the 1660s,
Milton was always continually
representing himself in just
this same light.
With the help of Milton's own
aggressively propagandistic
efforts, the English had begun
to fulfill the promise of
something like a full-fledged
revolution,
but the weak-minded
parliamentary leaders had failed
to carry it out;
and out of some sort of moral
weakness, the English people
began to yearn again for
subjection to the Stuart
monarchy.
It's in response to the tone of
political disappointment that we
can read in Samson Agonistes
that scholars are led to
date this work as a late one,
as a final poem -- the final
poem.Now,
the second theory of the date
of the composition of Samson
Agonistes places it in the
late 1640s,
in the period somewhere between
1647 and 1653.
This reading suggests that
Samson Agonistes
constitutes Milton's first
great response to the onset of
his blindness.
By placing the poem in this
period -- and you can tell what
scholars are responding to in
the poem with this theory.
They're clearly trying to make
some sense of the tremendous
amount of pathos,
and you could actually say the
tremendous amount of self-pity,
that charges Milton's treatment
of Samson's blindness.Now,
the third theory of the poem's
composition places it even
earlier in Milton's career
during the early 1640s.
This is the period in which
Milton was writing the divorce
pamphlets.
In this account,
the center of the poem becomes
a reflection,
or some sort of representation,
of the betrayal Milton must
have experienced himself when
his wife of six weeks,
Mary Powell,
left him -- just abandoned him
it seemed.
She went home to her parents.
Now in the poem,
in Samson Agonistes,
Dalila you'll remember --
she was a Philistine.
She was a member of a political
tribe that had so oppressed the
Hebrews -- and Mary Powell's
family had all been royalist
during the English civil wars,
and so to some extent perhaps
Mary Powell herself was a
royalist.
The leanings,
at least, of the Powell family,
it has been conjectured,
contributed significantly to
what turned out to be merely the
temporary erosion of Milton's
first marriage.
According to this theory then,
the main thrust of Samson
Agonistes isn't exclusively
political, but it's domestic --
or domestic and political.
Milton uses a biblical story to
reinvent, and in some way to
work through,
the private disaster that was
the early portion of his
marriage to Mary Powell.Now,
I think the third theory is --
it has to be wrong,
that Samson Agonistes
was written so early in
Milton's career in the 1640s.
But I am personally much too
invested in the notion that this
is the last poem to have its
status be relinquished as a
post-Restoration work.
Nonetheless,
I want to think about that
third option that I've just
mentioned and to focus on the
nature of Milton's
representation of the relation
of Samson to Dalila in this
poem,
which is an undeniably powerful
aspect of this work.Let me
just digress here for a moment
and explain to you why I
pronounce her name "Dalila" and
not "Delilah".
When I use the word "Delilah"
in this lecture,
that will be referring to the
character in the Old Testament
from the Book of Judges -- the
name with an h on the
end.
Milton doesn't have an h
on the end.
He uses the Latin spellings
from the Latin Bible of all of
the characters in Samson
Agonistes.
So the father is Manoa
rather than Manoah.
He makes up the name Harapha,
but it's along the same sort of
Latin lines of Dalila and Manoa.
Who knows why Milton wants to
classicize these names rather
than using the English
transliteration of the Hebrew!
It's been conjectured that it
just sounds prettier.
You have a line like "the
sumptuous Dalila floating this
way," those extraordinary
dactyls that seem incredibly so
sensual and seductive.
You couldn't have that with
Delilah, "the sumptuous Delilah
floating this way."
It just doesn't -- it's not as
sexy.Okay.
That was just a pronunciation
digression.
Now the evidence for the
scholars who date this poem as a
really early one is usually
taken from a scene in Milton's
life that actually was narrated
for us by Milton's nephew,
Edward Phillips.
So I'm going to ask you to turn
to Milton's nephew's,
Edward Phillips',
biography of Milton at the end
of the Hughes edition --
this is page 1032 in the
Hughes.
This is Phillips' account
of how Milton and Mary Powell
reunited, and it's an absolutely
adorable narrative.
It involves an elaborate trick
staged by friends of both Milton
and of Powell.
So we learn here -- it's an
amazing little window onto what
the texture of this man's life
was like -- that Milton was
evidently in the habit,
in the six weeks he lived alone
as the abandoned husband,
of visiting a friend.
We don't know who this guy was,
but according to Phillips --
this is the top of the
right-hand column -- it was at
Blackborough's house that the
scheme to reunite the couple,
to reunite them, was pulled off.
I'm quoting here from Phillips:
One time above the rest,
he [John Milton]
making his usual visit,
the wife was ready in another
room,
and on a sudden he was
surprised to see one whom he
thought to have never seen more,
making submission and begging
pardon on her knees before him.
He might probably at first make
some show of aversion and
rejection;
but partly his own generous
nature [this is the loving
Phillips who so admires the
uncle],
more inclinable to
reconciliation than to
perseverance in anger and
revenge,
and partly the strong
intercession of friends on both
sides, soon brought him to an
act of oblivion and a firm
league of peace for the
future.
And Mary Powell and John Milton
get back together again,
and they have a child -- they
have a few children.
This scene bears an obvious
resemblance to the initial
entrance of Dalila into the
poem,
Samson Agonistes.Now
there's no proof,
of course, that Milton's
Samson is a reworking of
this biographical event in the
stormy life that was Milton's
domestic -- the stormy career
[laughs]
of Milton's domestic life.
There's no proof that this
event ever happened at all.
My guess actually is that
Phillips, who's writing this
biographical narrative well
after the publication of
Samson Agonistes,
is actually staging his
account of this moment in
Milton's life in some way as a
reworking of the analogous
moment from Samson Agonistes.
I think he's giving us an
imaginative engagement of
Samson Agonistes,
and it's probably
because he wants to stave off
what he knows will be the easy,
obvious biographical reading
that we will bring to Milton's
poetic representation of a
perfectly disastrous
marriage.So I don't actually
trust Phillips' biography here,
but I want to linger on this
passage for just another moment
because I think it starts to
illuminate one of the most
puzzling aspects of Samson
Agonistes.
Look at Phillips' metaphor
in the last sentence that I just
quoted: Milton's "own generous
nature…
brought him to an act of
oblivion and a firm league of
peace for the future…"
Phillips is alluding here to
actual political events,
political events that took
place not in the 1640s -- when
we know this reunion occurred --
but after the Restoration.
The Act of Oblivion and the
League of Peace are both actual
political events that followed
the restoration of the Stuart
monarchy in 1660.So the
royalists in 1660 passed the Act
of Oblivion,
and the Act of Oblivion
prohibited any further
punishment of Puritans who were
seen to have behaved seditiously
during the revolution.
So in a gesture of magnanimity,
the royalists were agreeing to
be oblivious.
They would forget -- they would
forget the crimes of the Puritan
parliamentarians.
One of the most notable
beneficiaries,
in fact, of this Act of
Oblivion was Milton himself,
Milton whose life was,
I think, really mercifully
spared after the Restoration.
He could easily have been
prosecuted and executed for his
composition of the regicide
treatises.I think it's
fascinating what Phillips is
doing here.
He situates the relation of
husband and wife in the context
of a political accord,
a political agreement between
two warring parties.
In doing so,
he's reproducing,
I think, one of the strangest
aspects, and it is a really
strange aspect,
of this poem:
that's the remarkable
conjunction of the
representation of love and the
representation of war -- the
militaristic nature of sexual
relations in Samson Agonistes
and also the disturbingly
sexual nature of political
conflict as it's represented in
Samson Agonistes.
We'll pursue that in a
moment.One of the curious
elements of Phillips' account of
Mary Powell's return is the
implicit reversal,
I think, of political
identities here.
Milton becomes the royalist
passing the Act of Oblivion by
way of forgiving Mary Powell;
so these domestic enemies,
Powell and Milton,
have become -- it's as if
they've become mirror images of
one another.
The moral alignment of their
identities suddenly becomes,
in this retelling of it,
vague and indistinct.
In a lot of ways,
they're kind of pictured like
Satan and the Son of God in
Paradise Regained.
Satan in so many ways seems
to be the Son of God's evil
twin.
They're mirror images of one
another, but obviously they
represent utterly different
things.
The Son, you'll remember,
in Paradise Regained
only discovers his
identity in that poem in
opposition to Satan.
This is something that the late
poems of Milton are continually
doing: they're exploring what we
can think of as the dialectical
nature of identification.
Virtue cannot exist in a vacuum.
In fact, I think for Milton,
the knowledge of oneself can't
come about in a vacuum.
Any virtuous identity will
inevitably be the product of
some kind of antithetical
process,
of some sort of agonistic
encounter with one's
opposite.Now,
the antithetical construction
of the hero's identity is really
central to this poem,
Samson Agonistes,
and I think keeping this in
mind will help us try to make
sense of some of its most
troubling components.
I think the components [laughs]
of Samson Agonistes are
as troubling as anything you'll
find anywhere in the reading for
this course.
For me what's most troubling is
this fact -- and this is an
undeniable, unquestionable fact:
Samson Agonistes gives
us the intensest expression of
misogyny that you will find in
the Miltonic canon.
That's because this poem goes
further, I think,
than any of Milton's other
poems in narrowing the problem
of identity -- and this is a
problem that Milton has been
concerned with all along -- but
narrowing this larger problem of
identity to the much more
circumscribed and much more
focused problem of sexual
identity.The masculine
hero's identity can only be
established by contraries,
by some sort of antithetical
process.
Samson can only identify
himself as a hero by rejecting,
by actively excluding,
absolutely everything that's
not masculine,
rejecting everything that's not
heroic,
and rejecting everything that's
not Samson.
It becomes a kind of violent
process of rejection.
The character,
Samson, is continually
impelled, it seems,
by a powerful need to expel all
forms of sensual pleasure -- the
types of pleasure that we know
to be prized and sanctioned by
Milton -- that Milton will
identify in Samson Agonistes
as types of femininity,
and all of this has to be
expelled by Samson from
Samson.As you reread the
poem,
I think you'll be shocked -- if
you haven't been shocked already
-- by the violence of the really
weirdly sexualized rhetoric that
makes up so much of the
metaphorical texture of this
poem.
I'll give you just one example
-- there are innumerable
examples.
You may have noticed how this
poem refers routinely to the
Philistine enemies as "the
uncircumcised."
On some level this is to be
expected.
The Bible refers to heathens as
the uncircumcised,
and so this is conventional we
could say;
but Milton, of course,
needlessly goes further than
that.
He actually refers to the
enemies of the Hebrews as
"foreskins": "With his sword of
bone Samson slew a thousand
foreskins."
This is an unbelievable
synecdoche, synecdoche being the
rhetorical trope of using a part
for a whole,
and Milton, as far as I can
tell, had absolutely no
precedent whatsoever for the use
of this particular synecdoche to
refer to an entire people,
the uncircumcised enemies of
the Hebrews.There's a kind
of sexual violence continually
[laughs]
welling up in the rhetoric used
to describe political violence.
Think about what that [laughs]
implies.
To slay a thousand foreskins is
in some way to imagine a
military victory as something
like a mass circumcision or,
symbolically,
some type of mass castration.
This is just one of many
examples of a related kind of
figurative pattern in Samson
Agonistes.
Political violence seems so
continually to be figured in the
literary rhetoric of this poem
as a sexual cleansing,
as a kind of purging -- the
painful excision of something
unclean, something presumably
unnecessary,
and something excessively
sensual.Look,
for example,
at the way this text sexualizes
the key event in Samson's life,
which is of course,
the loss of his hair.
Look at Samson's account of the
moment at which he lost his
strength.
This is page 564 in the
Hughes, lines 529 and
following.
Now in the Book of Judges,
Samson tells Delilah that the
secret of his strength lies in
his hair only after her
continued verbal assaults.
She pleads with him,
she nags him -- she pleads with
him unremittingly to tell her
his secret, and finally he just
relents.
That's the scriptural story;
but in Samson's account in
Milton's story,
Dalila doesn't harass Samson in
to telling the secret -- she
seduces him.
Look at line 529.
This is Samson talking,
and here he describes himself
as the cock of the walk here:
Fearless of danger,
like a petty God
I walk'd about admir'd of all
and dreaded
On hostile ground,
none daring my affront.
Then swoll'n with pride into
the snare I fell
Of fair fallacious looks,
venereal trains,
Softn'd with pleasure and
voluptuous life…
Now, the voluptuous life that
he's describing here in line 534
is -- what is this?
I think this is what we would
have to name the life of
marriage.
The woman he's calling a
deceitful concubine is actually,
in Milton's telling of the
story,
Samson's wife,
and there's a profound
confusion about the cause of his
weakness here.
Was it the actual act of his
head being shaved or simply the
condition of marriage
itself?Listen to Milton's
figuration of the event of the
cutting of his hair,
and you tell me if this isn't
unusually charged,
even for Milton,
with a pretty intense degree of
sexual anxiety:
At length to lay my head
and hallow'd pledge
Of all my strength in the
lascivious lap
Of a deceitful Concubine who
shore me
Like a tame Wether,
all my precious
fleece…
You have an image here of
sexual intercourse -- this has
been suggested in a brilliant
reading of this poem by John
Guillory -- embedded in the
image of Samson's head in
Dalila's lascivious lap.
Her violation of Samson,
her cutting of his hair,
seems almost inextricable here
from a perfectly simple,
seemingly -- it's never simple
of course -- but an act of
conjugal intercourse.But the
figurative chain doesn't end
there.
It gets better or worse
[laughs]
depending on your perspective,
because in this play marital
intercourse is equated,
at least figuratively,
with castration -- the cutting
off of the hallowed pledge of
Samson's strength.
Samson makes this explicit when
he describes himself as "a tame
Wether."
"Well, what is a wether?"
you ask.
A wether is a castrated ram.
The slayer of a thousand
foreskins is himself slain,
and part of the intensely
violent figurative world of
Samson Agonistes -- this
is a world that continually
identifies Dalila's betrayal as
a kind of castration,
and castration itself is
nothing more than the male
experience in marriage.
A darker or more anxious
reading of the relation between
the sexes you'll have a
difficult time finding.Let's
look now at Dalila's own
language.
Turn to page 570 in the
Hughes, around line 803.
I think Dalila's language is in
a lot of ways just as powerful,
though it's configured a little
differently.
Much more than Samson,
Dalila contradicts herself
throughout this poem,
and the contradictions have
proven baffling to the poem's
critics.
One way of reading the
character, Dalila,
is to insist that her
contradictions point out,
emphasize, her mendacity.
These are just simply lies that
she's telling,
and in a lot of ways,
Milton does seem to be setting
her up as a type of Satan,
Satan who on Mount Niphates at
the beginning of Book Four of
Paradise Lost was
continually contradicting
himself.Critics have
typically dismissed Dalila's
explanations,
her justifications of her
behavior, with the assumption
that Milton is simply trying to
discredit her.
It's not an unjustifiable
assumption, and I think that's
because the central
contradiction of her discourse
involves her use of two types of
arguments.
The first is an erotic,
a romantic, argument and the
second argument she deploys is a
political one.
Once again, it's this
conjunction, the conjunction of
the sexual and the political,
that in this poem proves so
unsettling and so puzzling.
So let's look at Dalila's
reasons for betraying her
husband.
This is her first argument,
line 803.
She's essentially saying,
"I wanted you at home.
You were always going out.
You were working all the time":
I knew that liberty
Would draw thee forth to
perilous enterprises,
While I at home sate full of
cares and fears
Wailing thy absence in my
widow'd bed;
Here I should still enjoy thee
day and night [here at home]
Mine and Loves
prisoner…
"I unmanned you," she's saying,
"because I loved you so much."
That's the gist of the
argument.Dalila's second
argument is entirely different,
and it's distinct from the
complaint of the housewife that
we just looked at.
Look at the very bottom of page
571 -- this is line 857 and
following.
Here Dalila tells us that she
had to betray Samson for
political reasons;
she had to do it to liberate
her people, the Philistines:
[T]he Priest
Was not behind [Dalila says]
but ever at my ear,
Preaching how meritorious with
the gods
It would be to ensnare an
irreligious
Dishonorer of Dagon: what had I
To oppose against such powerful
arguments?
Only my love of thee held long
debate,
And combated in silence all
these reasons
With hard contest:
at length that grounded maxim
So rife and celebrated in the
mouths
Of wisest men;
that to the public good
Private respects must yield,
with grave authority
Took full possession of me and
prevail'd;
Vertue, as I thought,
truth, duty so enjoyning.
And Dalila here gives us an
extraordinary revelation:
on some level,
she turns out to be the mirror
image of the great,
heroic Samson.
She plays the same role as the
deliverer of her people -- she's
the deliverer of the Philistines
-- that Samson plays for the
Hebrews.
She defends the gentile god,
Dagon, and Samson,
her husband,
defends the Hebrew god,
Yahweh or Jehovah.
They're in direct competition
here.
They're political opposites,
and Milton is playing with
something approaching a sort of
cultural relativism by means of
his representation of this
competition.There is,
however, a difference between
them, and it's a difference we
have no choice but to deal with.
The difference between them is
that Dalila, the wife,
sacrifices private concerns for
a public commitment to her
people.
In her words,
she yields "private respects"
to "the public good."
This is precisely what Samson
was supposed to do,
but of course,
this is exactly what Samson
failed to do.
So in a lot of ways,
these two explanations,
these two arguments of
Dalila's, contradict one
another.
On the literal level of the
plot the first motive,
the motive appropriate for a
wife, is revealed as a lie;
but the presence of these two
conflicting motives bespeaks
more, I think,
than the mere fact that Dalila
is a liar or that in some way
Dalila is a satanic figure who's
just a very embodiment of evil.
These two conflicting arguments
really speak to Samson's deepest
anxieties and perhaps the
deepest anxieties of this poem,
Samson Agonistes.The
prospect of domestic pleasure is
invariably a dangerous one for
Samson,
and that's because domestic
success, success at home,
for Samson is indistinguishable
from political defeat.
Dalila's two arguments are
utterly -- it's as if inside of
Samson's head they're utterly
intermingled with one another,
inextricable in Samson's psyche.
In the severely restricted,
circumscribed world of this
hero's consciousness,
domestic comfort and political
failure turn out to be something
like one and the same thing.
In both instances the hero is
seen to have relinquished his
masculinity.
He has undergone a humiliating
defeat, and with this dual
identification of Dalila as wife
and as fierce warrior,
you have a powerful sense of
the fragility of masculine
heroic consciousness as it's
represented in this
text.Okay.
Turn now to Dalila's final
offer to Samson.
This is at line 920,
the middle of the Hughes' page
573.
The most tempting and the most
terrifying offer of Dalila's is
her offer to nurse Samson --
he's old,
he's blind -- to nurse him
after his release from the
prison.
So Dalila tells Samson:
I to the Lords will
intercede, not doubting
Thir favourable ear,
that I may fetch thee
From forth this loathsom
prison-house to abide
With me, where my redoubl'd
love and care
With nursing diligence,
to me glad office,
May ever tend about thee to old
age…
With her "nursing diligence,"
Dalila can be Samson's nurse.
Better yet, she can function as
Samson's mother -- I think
that's essentially the gist of
her argument -- since it is
already claimed we know -- this
was at line 633 -- he's claimed
that he is a nursling of God.
He's been struggling throughout
this text to establish himself
as a child not of human parents,
certainly not of the perfectly
sweet nature but the kind of
addled dad of his,
Manoa, but he's a child solely,
exclusively of God
himself.It's Dalila's offer
to nurse Samson that elicits his
most violent,
most powerful, fit of rage.
It's horrible.
Look at line 952.
Dalila says:
"Let me approach at least,
and touch thy hand."
And Samson's response?
Shocking: "Not for thy life,
lest fierce remembrance wake /
my sudden rage to tear thee
joint by joint."
Dalila's simple offer to touch
Samson's hand has received
[laughs]
an extraordinarily extreme
reaction.
It's usually thought -- this is
typically how we read this,
I think -- that the fierce
remembrance that will awaken
Samson is his memory of his
powerful desire for her,
a memory that he has to
forestall with this violent
rejection.But I think the
violence of this reaction surely
exceeds the violence merely of a
remembered sexual passion.
This is too intense even for
that, and I think it's possible
to see in this reaction to
Dalila's offer to nurse Samson
another memory that has been
suppressed.
It's not just the remembrance
of sexual love.
Our best clue to this
suppressed memory might come
from that aspect of the story of
Samson from the Book of Judges
that has been most noticeably
suppressed -- perhaps it's been
circumcised -- from Milton's own
poem.
You'll remember from your
reading of the poem that Milton
is continually referring to the
heavenly messenger who descended
to prophecy Samson's
greatness.This was happening
well before Samson was actually
born -- but to whom?
To whom did this heavenly
messenger speak?
According to the Judges story,
the angel spoke to Samson's
mother, a character who figures
prominently in the scriptural
original of the story but who is
very carefully excluded from the
text of Samson Agonistes.
I'm indebted for this point
to a wonderful reading of this
poem by -- I think she's a great
Milton critic,
her name is Stevie Davies.
In Samson's violent rejection
of Dalila, in his rejection of
her offer to nurse him in his
old age,
Samson is rejecting on some
level the very existence of his
mother.
He's denying the obvious fact
that he had ever been mothered
at all, which is another way,
of course, of denying his
humanity, of denying his status
as a creature and his
createdness.Now,
it has been years now -- Milton
has for years addressed himself
to the attraction and also to
the danger of the fantasy of
heroic self-sufficiency.
I'll just remind you of Book
Five of Paradise Lost in
which Milton explored the
fantasy of self-creation,
Satan's remarkable and of
course implausible claim that he
was self-begot.
Satan needed to deny,
he wanted to deny,
God's agency in his creation.
Now Samson's case is related
but, of course,
it's a little different.
Samson wants more than anything
to be a nursling of God,
and it's as if he needs to deny
that he had ever had any tie to
the womb or to the breast of an
earthly mother if he is to be
the nursling exclusively of God.
Of course, it's the fact,
the existence of the mother,
that is the thing that
guarantees the truth,
which is that he is inescapably
human;
but like us,
Samson obviously owes a
fundamental physical debt,
a fundamental physiological
debt and obligation,
to a mother.There's a sense
in this poem that the very
existence of the mother,
of any mother,
seems to doom all of our
attempts to think of ourselves
as independent,
as autonomous,
and in any way self-sufficient
beings, or to think of ourselves
as beings whose primary debt can
be exclusively to the heavenly
father.
Milton had been so bold in
Paradise Regained to
emphasize the thoroughgoing
humanity of the Son of God.
The Son of God in Paradise
Regained had no more divine
knowledge about his situation,
it seemed, than we could
possibly have had.
It's in that [laughs]
poem where Milton should have
been anxious about the humanity
of the hero,
but all of that theological
anxiety that should have existed
in Paradise Regained
seems to have been displaced
onto Samson
Agonistes.Turn to the
very opening of Samson
Agonistes,
the exquisitely beautiful
lines with which Milton begins
this poem: "A little onward lend
thy guiding hand / to these dark
steps,
a little further on…"
Milton's poem opens with these
beautiful lines addressed by
Samson to someone,
presumably, who's holding his
hand, who is touching his hand
and assisting his movements in
his blindness -- Samson's
wandering steps and slow.
This sense of absolute
dependence with which we begin
this poem is overwhelming.
It's often argued that Milton
is suggesting here something
like Samson's complete
dependence on God.
This is the nursling of God,
after all.
Samson's ultimate victory comes
from his absolute submission to
the will of God.This much we
will learn at the end of the
poem but the character -- it's a
character in fact,
it's not the Divinity -- the
character leading Samson around
at the opening of the play is
never named.
This character is never
identified, and this mysterious
omission certainly has to be
purposeful;
this is another clever argument
forwarded by Stevie Davies.
The unnamed character holding
Samson's hand reminds us here of
another unnamed character in the
Samson story,
and that's of course Samson's
mother.
Samson as the champion of the
Hebrews is supposed to be able
to submit himself utterly to the
will of the Father,
not Manoa but the heavenly
Father, but the play reminds us
overwhelmingly and continually
that even the greatest heroes
are subject -- and you can tell
that Milton was an enormous fan
of Shakespeare's tragedy,
Coriolanus,
which explores a lot of the
same problems -- but even the
greatest heroes are subject to
other far less dignified forms
of submission.
That human figure most likely
to lend a hand to unsteady steps
is obviously the mother,
the person in the child's life
who touches the child's hand and
serves as his first guide,
first teacher.In
Paradise Regained,
after all that we went through
in Paradise Regained,
Milton was able to allow
the Son to return home to his
mother's house:
"hee unobserv'd / Home to his
Mother's house private
return'd."
The Son of God had successfully
proven his son-ship to the
heavenly Father,
and he could thereby afford to
return to the domestic space.
Of course, it's a domestic
space that had been utterly
purged of any type of
sensuality,
but in Samson Agonistes
the space,
the place of maternal affection
and domestic peace -- of just
happiness in one's domestic life
-- is continually threatening to
contaminate the hero,
and obviously this is a hero
who's a lot less well adjusted,
we could say,
than the Son of God.That
didn't make any sense but on
some level,
at least to me, it does.
Heroism in this poem depends on
the hero's ability to exclude,
to expunge from his system,
any attachment to the home,
any dependency on an origin
that could compete with the
ultimate origin,
which is of course that of the
Heavenly Father.
That's why this poem is
continually voicing its terrible
conviction in the necessary
exclusion of all things
feminine.
It's in respect,
I think, to this exclusion that
we can best understand the
horrible violence and the
terrible misogyny charging the
language of Samson Agonistes.
This poem,
this play that's not really a
play, seems to be arguing for
the necessary exclusion of the
feminine from the hero's life.
If that's true,
if that is one of the ultimate
arguments that Samson
Agonistes is actually
making,
then I think we also have in
this poem the pained and also
the painful rhetoric -- we have
the painful sense that Milton
gives us of the cost of that
exclusion.
Here in Milton's final poem,
we have an acknowledgment that
the process whereby one becomes
a Miltonic hero is potentially
ruinous.Okay.
That's it for today.